not everyone looked backward in the 80s
it's true now before I reveal the rest
of the couch I'll do I'll do a little
bit of self-harm this this is me in the
80s I know why I addressed it Becky
joki I was never a jockey I don't
remember that time in my life
uh-huh this this will frighten you
this is mr. Harry Hill in the eighties I
was very serious very serious you
scientists I wasn't mad scientist you
look like you're like cloning weird got
a dog's they can talk today that's my
hair fella I just noticed it was taking
longer and longer to wash my face
basically very wide middle parting yeah
sad reset and meanwhile in Leicester
ladies gentlemen a young footballer had
just stepped onto the pitch you've
thrown into yourself
my acne stage and thank you he's
better-looking now right Jessica yes yes
yeah you're cute as a kid though I think
yeah
there's a million bats Stacy and I
wanted to be there when all the bats are
coming out of the cave so I could say
something like that's a million bats
commander how much - oh let me get too
weird this is weird okay so tell us how
much you like David